ah
había una vez una hermosa muñeca de
dorados cabellos vibrante piel bronceada
largas y torneadas piernas y una silueta
de reloj de arena de ensueño esta chica
lo tenía todo lo podía todo el chico
perfecto el trabajo perfecto la vida
perfecta su belleza él abría todas las
puertas
ella era perfección seguramente tú igual
la reconoces quizá jugaste con ella y
poco a poco fuiste haciendo tuyas estas
ideas si eras como ella lo tendrías todo
entonces alguna vez has comparado tu
cuerpo con el de esa famosa muñeca o el
de otras mujeres te has sentido
avergonzada por alguna cicatriz o
velocidad
seguramente conoces a alguien
desesperada por teñirse las camas es más
cuántas veces te has puesto a dieta o
quizá eres de los que reniegan del
imperdonable celulitis flacidez estrías
tono o textura de la piel todas las
mujeres sin excepción en algún punto de
nuestra vida nos hemos sentido inseguras
con respecto a nuestro cuerpo
limitándonos de manera inconsciente para
luchar por nuestros sueños pero hoy
quiero demostrarle a todas las mujeres
que son hermosas y valiosas tal y como
son que en la medida que lo crean y
celebren un nuevo y maravilloso mundo de
posibilidades se abrirá para ellas
implícitamente pero siempre una de esas
tres ya tengo muchas durante mucho mucho
tiempo me critique desprecie mi cuerpo y
me odia a mi misma por creer que de su
imagen frente al espejo y no soy la
única de acuerdo con un estudio piloto
realizado en la ciudad de mexico en el
año 2015 78 si escucharon bien 78% de
las mujeres que fueron encuestadas entre
los 25 y los 35 años de edad dijo estar
altamente insatisfecha con su cuerpo y
no sólo eso sino que estaría dispuesto
lo que fuera para tener el cuerpo
perfecto implícitamente empezamos a
creer que valemos en la medida que somos
reconocidas por nuestro cuerpo en cuanto
a las pasiones levantamos con cuántos
likes somos capaces de coleccionar
nuestras redes sociales
esperamos a nosotras mismas con base en
lo que otra persona opina de nuestro
cuerpo y a la capacidad que éste tiene
para encajar en un molde perfecto de
belleza un molde que dicho sea de paso
deja de lado lo que somos nuestra
esencia la herencia genética nuestra
raza condiciones médicas e incluso
accidentes por ejemplo si yo provengo de
una familia latina con tendencia al
sobrepeso y tengo una deficiencia
hormonal puede alergia alergia al yodo
es muy poco probable que yo sea
naturalmente rubia mide 180 ips 65 kilos
estos factores pueden hacer muy difícil
si no es que imposible lograr estos
estándares de perfección que
influenciados por los medios de
comunicación hemos aceptado y que como
sociedad normalizamos qué pasa entonces
cuando no encajamos cuando no logramos
cumplir con las expectativas cuando sin
importar lo que hagas o cuánto te
esfuerces no logras verte como la chica
de la portada de tu revista favorita
como esa actriz de moda que todos desean
o como aquella chica que todo lo podía
nos volvemos vulnerables cuando no nos
amamos a nosotras mismas
cuando dudamos nuestro valor y no nos
creemos capaces cuando el mundo no nos
da siquiera la oportunidad de demostrar
de lo que somos capaces de hasta dónde
podemos llegar
vivimos sin satisfechas no somos felices
de ser quien es y como somos nos
volvemos sumisas complacientes nuestra
necesidad de aceptación nos hace más
propensas a caer en situaciones de
violencia a las destructivas al grado de
pensar que se nos falta no sobra para
poder merecer lo que deseamos
lo más triste y alarmante de todo esto
es que dejamos el estándar tan pero tan
bajo que cualquiera pasa por encima de
nuestra integridad sueños autoestima
etcétera incluso nosotras mismas
todo esto lo viví desde muy pequeño la
verdad es que si quedan diez centavos
por vez que alguien me ha dicho mar y si
es tan bonita
lástima que usted es gordita probable
que hoy ya sería millonaria
y es que durante muchos años luché
contra mi cuerpo me avergoncé de él lo
odie y lo trate con desprecio
sometiéndolo a todo tipo de recetas
milagrosas píldoras mágicas dietas
insanas y rutinas extenuantes de
ejercicio que llevaron mi cuerpo al
límite
en 2014 tras casi un año de ser
vegetariana me obsesione para simios
pero obsesione con lograr bajar de peso
así que juntó una dieta y unas píldoras
mágicas me dediqué a caminar una hora
todas las mañanas y por las tres me
aventaba dos horas de cardio en el yo
aquí pasaron días semanas meses
hasta que un día me desmayé en el
gimnasio
pero la báscula y la cinta métrica
apenas
y cambiaban
me sentía tan pero tan frustrada
derrotada tenía miedo tenía mucho mucho
miedo de no lograrlo nunca
de no merecer todos los que desde
chiquita me dijeron que debía de ser y
soñar
tenía pánico de no ser reconocida nunca
como la increíble mujer que soy pero que
no se ve como todos esperan
hasta que un día recibió un regalo muy
especial mi mamá me había hecho una
muñeca
una muñeca cualquiera esto era una
muñeca que se veía exactamente como yo
con las curvas donde yo las tengo mis
lonjas mis lunares mis cicatrices mis
estrías todo el color y el estilo de
cabello como yo lo tenía y además
vestido en bikini lucía increíble más
que hermosa se veía poderosa fuerte y
aún así femenina todo lo que desde hacía
tanto tiempo no me sentía
verla me traje una avalancha de
emociones fue como un balde de agua fría
al alma que movió las heridas pero que
me confrontó conmigo misma
tras varios días de observarla y de
observar me a través de ella mi muñeca
se convirtió en este impulso que
necesitaba para reencontrarme fue la
perfecta compañera del proceso
terapéutico que inicié y que me ayuda a
reconstruir me
a reconocer esas limitaciones de mi
cuerpo ya mantenerme sana aceptando me
desde el amor
toda esta experiencia fue tan
trascendente tan transformadora
que decidimos que teníamos que
compartirla con otras mujeres sentíamos
esa enorme necesidad me asocié con mi
mamá y junto a mi familia iniciamos esta
empresa social dedicada a ayudar a las
mujeres a vivir estos procesos de
sanación de amor propio
en 2017 por fin la pusimos en marcha y
hoy a poco más de un año de haber
iniciado
hemos logrado darle la vuelta al mundo
impactando positivamente la vida de
miles de personas nuestras muñecas
personalizadas le han dado la vuelta al
mundo ayudando a cientos de mujeres en
29 estados de la república y 16 países
cuando tú dejas de perseguir estos
ideales de un velo de belleza dejas de
vivir para complacer a otros y logras
centrarte en ti
confías cada día un poco más en tu
capacidad descubres que todas esas voces
críticas que tratan de inyectar te su
negatividad y miedo son mentirosas y
dejas de escucharlas vives en positivo
te rodeas de gente que está en tu misma
sintonía detectas oportunidades tomas
acción para convertir tus sueños en
realidad logras transformar todo ese
dolor en oportunidades para vivir un
presente feliz y es entonces cuando un
día por fin desarrollas al espejo eres
solidaria con otras mujeres te aceptas
te perdonas temporeras logras que el
mundo se enamore de ti y descargas que
la clave de todo está en la actitud
porque mientras crees en ti
así como a mi muñeca ya mí no importa
cuántas veces la vida trate de
aplastarte siempre vas a hacer paz de
ponerte de pie y con más fuerza que
antes muchas gracias
[Aplausos]